from comicbook.com because the boycotts
are getting crazier doctor disrespect
boycott's Call of Duty following Nick
Mark's controversy they say following
the uh Call of Duty has enjoyed an
absurd level of success blah blah blah
last night Nick merkskin was removed
from the game etc etc we know this
doctor disrespect uninstalled Call of
Duty and said he won't return until they
apologize or add Nick Mark's operator
bundled back into the game for those
that are just tuning in Nick marks a
prominent streamer with I think like
eight million five no he's got more than
he's got six million on Twitch he's got
four million on YouTube he's got 2
million on Twitter said leave the little
children alone that's it so they ax him
from the game now you've got this guy Dr
disrespect who's extremely also with
millions of followers saying I won't
play the game till they apologize what
we are seeing is a major shift I don't
know if Bud Light has anything to do
with it but I wonder
if after everyone saw a 30 sales drop
from Bud Light for doing this two things
happened people became less afraid
thinking hey you know what if I speak
out I can clearly see most people are on
my side and the other thing was
opportunists thought it was popular and
they jumped on board well it also now
real quick just now you have more
prominent high-profile people willing to
boycott powerful Brands over going in
this direction yeah the blood light
Fiasco and boycott and success of the
boycott globally showed people globally
that you have control with social media
of markets and now they're emboldened
and are willing to twist the market at
will uh it can go bad as well I mean it
can go in any direction depending on
what side you're on I've always been
concerned about people like organizing
um a mass withdrawal of money from a
bank on a day when trying to crash the
economy Bradley I wanted to ask you on
this I know you talk a lot about ESG you
mentioned Target and what's going on
with Activision now could you explain to
us what ESG is and does that play into
any of this at all yeah ESG does play
into this actually so Anheuser-Busch
right uh guess who one of the largest
shareholders are van heuser-busch inbev
black BlackRock BlackRock black is and
Vanguard and so what since they are some
of the largest shareholders through the
dollars that they manage in retirement
funds and everything else they have
massive amounts of voting power there
and so what they do is push initiatives
like this at board meetings because
they've been able to install their board
of directors on those corporate Boards
of governance and that's how we get here
and that's how decisions like this get
made in simple terms what is ESG for
people who don't understand plain
language and how does it affect those so
very short and quick ESG which stands
for environmental social governance what
it is doing it's forcing dollars towards
ideas instead of returns which is the
opposite of the free market dollars
should flow towards returns not ideas
and what they are doing is coercing
Capital towards ideas instead of returns
and which is going to ultimately I think
destroy the free mark Market in this
country you know Vanguard State Street
in BlackRock I noticed with almost every
public company we talk about has about
22 percent the three companies combine
BlackRock Vanguard State Street have
about 22 of all these public companies
22 22 of Microsoft of apple and it's
they never really have that much more
they never really have that much less so
with 22 what kind of board power can you
access well I mean think about what is
Elon know of Twitter right I mean isn't
it like 13 something like that like
controlling interest or something but I
mean when he uh ended up buying it uh I
think the amount of stock that it took
to get there so right he owns it
entirely he owns it entirely now but the
amount of uh so 13 couldn't get him what
he wanted right so he had to buy it out
yeah he had to buy it out and but that
amount of uh leverage that they have
like each one owning 22 22. each one
owns about seven percent yeah yeah seven
percent but these guys in totality cast
of every vote cast on every publicly
traded company in the country and the
asset Center management that they have
is larger than the GDP of the United
States in a given year so it's it's not
just about voting though voting voting
with 25 power doesn't sound like a whole
lot the bigger the bigger issue is if
they went to they have seven percent of
insert company and they go and they say
we're holding about 250 million dollars
of your company
if you don't do this I'm sorry we're
going to have to protect our clients by
selling off all of this stock which will
cause a panic and a dump on your company
and they're all three coordinated in
their approach I mean 22 look I mean is
a substantial amount of control given I
mean depending on the publicly traded
company that you're talking about
and it gives them a tremendous amount of
Leverage Exxon Mobil was a great example
uh BlackRock was certainly not a
majority stakeholder there but through
working through proxies who they were
able to put onto the board activist
members in 2021 they were able to put
board members on there coordinating with
their other uh ESG woke capitalist uh
buddies they put activist board members
on there that moved and were successful
in reducing oil production at Exxon
Mobil by 20 and increasing green energy
production by 20 which then I guess we
could use that oil production right
about now right with gas prices so can
you uh it was three companies right
three firms yes State Street Vanguard
Black Rock okay so who owns BlackRock uh
well BlackRock is publicly traded right
right so who's got the who's got the
largest stake in those come and let's
say BlackRock well yeah I mean Larry
Finks who like the like the one of the
top guys well do you want to know who
the yeah those are yeah first we have
the Vanguard group yeah next we have
State Street Corp yeah then we have Bank
of America and there's a list of others
the buy I just highlight this because
they own each other yeah and Larry
himself owns a significant amount in in
there as well who's the CEO of it is yes
they but they all do own each other and
so there is you know and look if I'm
elected to congress these guys got to
get in my view they need to get broken
up yeah for sure I'm looking at
BlackRock Inc in its own five percent of
it's owned by BlackRock fund advisors
yes Riley for a moment I wanted to
follow up on this ESG stuff and um kind
of play The Devil's Advocates role
because a lot of people are pushing for
this many people are saying that free
markets aren't working for everybody
across our countries now nowadays and we
need to start worrying about the
stakeholders I.E employees or workers
more than just the shareholders like
where the capital is coming from how
would you respond to somebody who's
saying this is really about helping
workers yes stakeholder capitalism is
fake that is not a real thing
stakeholder capitalism so when we in in
West Virginia India we did a restricted
financial institution list for companies
that were boycotting the fossil fuel
industry and I spoke to a lot of the
biggest financial institutions in the
country
and the end of the day a publicly traded
company their job is to maximize
shareholder value right and when I
talked to them I said uh well what what
stakeholder capitalism to you and
they're like well you know people that
have different interests we have uh you
know communities of color indigenous
people we have uh green energy we have
environmentalists and this and that I
said well what about the shareholder
where they fit into they're like well
they're one of the stakeholders let me
just kind of real real quick go just one
second to insert this pull this up
according to Yahoo finance the top
institutional stakeholder of Vanguard is
Blackrock it is you are right crazy it
should be broken up yeah anyway anyway
the follow-up was going to be that like
often times that because it's uh this is
what people would argue that when it's
just the shareholders in charge some
companies get gutted out and it doesn't
help the workers and some people are
just looking to benefit on the back end
stock side Finance side of it so that
that's kind of yeah the sharehold
older shareholder capitalism I mean is
not helping the employees sure so
exactly the stakeholder capitalism the
idea of it is although the devil's in
the details and it does
it does but but
I misspoke there so in in terms of
shareholders some of these guys do get
some type of stock option and blah blah
blah and some of this the share or the
um stakeholder stakeholder version of
that it's not helping the employees
either I mean this didn't help me like
so at Exxon mobil's board it's not a
bunch of employees that said like we
want to reduce oil production so we're
working less no this was pushed by
BlackRock and then engine one which was
a former employee of BlackRock who
started their own company and were able
to uh get onto that board to help
facilitate bringing these uh leftists
onto the board to try to destroy Exxon
Mobil from the inside out
um I mean all this does is essentially
redefine and this is where it gets
slippery and this is by Design what risk
is right what risk is what how do you
define risk well they Define Risk by not
being diverse enough they Define Risk by
uh global climate change what they need
to Define risk is by the very simple uh
definitions what are called pecuniary
factors of material Financial Risk and
return they're going to end up
destroying people's retirement funds I
guess my I think the idea here is that
they're arguing that their version of
stakeholder capitalism is going to work
to employ um is going to work to help
the average employee I believe free
markets actually help the workers more
than what they're saying with
stakeholder capital and ESG I just want
to understand you don't think this is
actually helping the workers then this
isn't helping the workers at all because
that's what they're arguing that this is
for them no because you have Larry Fink
at the top of this thing right you know
over there Black Rock they all own each
other and they're all in coordination do
you think anybody in these publicly
traded companies have any Vote or any
say in this top down Larry Fink has made
very clear he was of course at the world
economic Forum just recently uh talking
to Aaron Sorkin and saying we are going
to force behaviors we're going to force
behaviors that is what we are going to
do we're going to enforce behaviors and
he has said
capitalism in his view this shareholder
cap stakeholder capitalism has the
ability
to
um has the ability to essentially
control people's behavior right has the
ability to shape the world is what he
said essentially I got a correction that
that last I showed wasn't Vanguard it
was a different company called American
Vanguard and they're they they're
confusing and it's actually very
difficult to find who are the largest
shareholders of Vanguard which is
different but I will I will pull it up
so Larry Fink says it has the ability to
shape Society but what if we don't want
the same shape of society that Larry
Fink does I want to interact I want to
interject on that the idea that we
should be shaping Society every time
that's been tried in human history it's
ended with piles and piles of dead
bodies yes when they TR like if you
listen to to Marx he talked about new
socialist man that normal that the man
that man is not ready for the Socialist
uh system you have to remake man
Nietzsche did the same thing when he
talked about the uberman the Ubermensch
the over man he believed that without
God man had to come up with his own new
morality and normal man us would not
understand
the over man's morality and the over man
isn't in any position or isn't obligated
to explain to us what they're trying to
do is nothing new like the idea that we
can reshape the world to prevent climate
change which I I mean there's a lot of
things that I have problems that I have
with the arguments for climate change
um but
the effort to remake Humanity always
ends with piles of dead bodies the Nazis
did it
the Communists did it more than once Pol
Pot two million people died in Cambodia
that was 20 percent of all of the people
in Cambodia there was eight million
people in Cambodia before Pol Pot they
killed two million people Mao tried to
change Mal believe that the sparrows
were caught were were a problem and they
weren't communist so they were TR they
were eating the seed and so he told all
the people in China Kill The Sparrows
Don't Let The Sparrows land and what
happened was because the sparrows were
not there to eat the bugs the bugs ate
all the crops and there was a famine and
millions of people died when you try to
affect the whole world when you try to
change mankind humans always screw it up
and it always ends in piles and piles
and piles of dead bodies this ESG stuff
is aimed at affecting climate change you
talk about the stuff that was going on
in I think it was the Dutch Farmers that
were having the problem that's because
they wanted to they wanted to limit how
much they could produce they want to
limit how much you can use fossil fuels
all of our fertilizer is fossil fuel
base it's all petrochemicals if you
don't have fertilizers then you're gonna
have famines millions and million if if
they are successful with the to in
getting control of basically the markets
Global markets there will be millions
and millions and millions and millions
of people probably a billion people that
will die of famine this is not
hyperbolic either all you have to do is
look at the 19th or at the look at the
the 20th century and see the death tolls
that have CA that were that were a
result of governments trying to reshape
human nature um I wanna real quick just
uh there's no shareholders of Vanguard
Vanguard says they're they're the only
investment management company owned by
its investors
basically means the people who put their
money in it they're quote unquote the
owners but it's someone still runs it
right it and the Phil's point on you
know if listening audience is curious
Nietzsche good luck at Will To Power
that's a book that he wrote yeah it's a
terrible book but uh but it look it's
it's very interesting because that is
kind of where we are right now but to
his point in Ireland they're telling
them that they're going to have to call
that means kill all of their cattle yeah
to reduce uh greenhouse gas emissions
from cows I mean this is how they've
lived there for centuries for centuries
right I mean so what is that going to do
to the island of Ireland the Republic of
Ireland right and the end of the day we
have this collusion as it relates to ESG
in between corporate power and left-wing
ideology so it's this Unholy merger of
corporate power and left-wing ideology
that you've seen before thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time